hey everyone my name is kashish kundu
and i will present my topic uh that is
in silico analysis of transcriptomic
responses to uv and ionization
radiations in human cells so
to understand the human response to dna
damage
we use the microarray data from a data
set that is gse in 1977
and
we use microarray to measure the
transcriptional responses of the genes
to ionization radiations ir
which is represented in shred in my
samples and
uv that is ultraviolet radiation is
represented as blue in my samples along
with one more sample is there that is
the mock which i represented with green
so there are many genes that are
involved in
our known dna
damage response pathways for cell
signaling proliferation and many other
metabolic pathways in our body
however the majority of the genes are
involved in unexpected pathways with
functions in signal transactions the rna
binding and editing and synthesis or
degradation of the protein
so i won't go into the methods of how
this data was uh
actually
extracted
but i'll just tell the brief about it
that
about 10 000
genes were analyzed in this sample which
were collected from total of 15 healthy
individuals without any history in
cancer and were immortalized with
epstein-barr virus
so to obtain a wide
genome-wide portrait of the
transcriptional response to dna damage
in human cells
oligonucleotides microarray was used to
measure the response of the genes in
cell lines for these different
individuals and the cell lines served as
replicates and allowed us to you know
identify responses that were indeed
that were independent of other
variations
among the different individuals
now the pipeline that i followed
here i identified gene identification i
selected a data set so for selection of
data set i
how i selected it is i was interested in
knowing how cancer
we get skin cancer
by
uv radiations basically sun rays so how
we uh humans are getting infected
the what is the effect of
sun rays on
our skin
so this was the particular paper which
was quite intriguing so i downloaded the
series matrix file
and i removed the unwanted information
and selected the gene
gene expression table
after grouping the data into mock ir and
uv i mentioned how i colored code them
this was the coding
mock green
red ir and blue uv
then i went for pc analysis of the data
and i was looking for some
i was experimenting with my pc analysis
so i went for three different types of
pca by comparing the mock with ir and uv
separately and all three together
then i went for statistical analysis
and calculated the p value
q value that is p adjusted value and log
fc value of the full change value
for these uh all this procedure i use
the t by info platform
and this platform is provided by uh pine
biotic
and for running these pipelines uh i use
this platform and you can see there are
so many pipelines that are here and it
gives a wider uh
it gives us a wide area of analysis here
for pc i use
unsupervised analysis and and the
utility
box also has pca there are some
different parameters
which you can follow here you can always
go to the tbi info server and look into
it
then this is the data set
this is the data set and you can see the
data set here this is the series matrix
table i have to remove i removed this
one and idrif i changed it to id i made
some relevant changes into it and
removed the
pre-documentation information that was
given
then i went for grouping the data i
grouped them is ir mock and uv
later on i went to pc analysis this is
the t by info platform here you can see
the result output that i could get i
have the text file for the pca i have a
zip folder which has all these files and
obviously the pdf plot
so you can see here
my
pca at first was not that good because
oh sorry
because there were many uh
the samples were forming a carpet
so there was not a good
distinct grouping was not there
for you
for all the three samples or the
individual or the individual samples so
i gave it a thought about it and i
thought that after sorting this data and
filtering the data maybe i could come
back and again do the pc analysis and
see if
i get some relevant information
for p value formula i used equals to t
dot test followed by the array one that
is the mock sample array 2
and the parameters
array 2 is the ir samples that i have
for p adjusted formula i use the formula
as is equal to
and then the af 144 is the p-value
when selecting the p-value later i
gave the max of
the counts
divided by a individual p-val individual
count of that p-value respectively
values
then for full change or log fc formula i
use the log of average of the mock
samples
divided by the
average of the
ir samples now in the same way i did it
for uv samples
once this was done now i was left with
how uh now as you all know for microwave
data we have the probe ids we don't have
the gene names and the gene ids so my
task was to get the
gene names and the genes gene ids so
i've used david here
david is the database for annotation
visualization and integrated discovery
these tools are powered by the
comprehensive
uh david knowledge base
and
that is built upon the dna
sorry on david gene concept which pulls
together all the multiple sources of
functional annotations
once these sources are collected
together they have various different
tools you can use and once
these one of the tool is gene name
batchview i choose that for changing the
probe ids into relevant gene ids
not actually changing for merging them
so i selected the sorted data
now for sorting the data how i sorted i
selected the q value as less than 0.05
and the
log fc value i choose it between 1 and 1
or minus 1.
so then i selected the data a whole file
and i went to the upload section and
put i just copied copy and pasted the
file here and selected the
some parameters changes here and hit
just hit run
after running i got the
david ids which which are actually the
probe ids
with the gene name and the gene id is
there you can see the gene ids are
written in the bracket
so
now the task that is left is merging the
data using r
so after merging the data
now i'll uh after merging the data i'll
go for path analysis using links tool
now links is also uh
it also has a wide range of tools for
performing pathway analysis and
statistical analysis and whatnot
it's a huge server
so in future prospect after path
analysis i'll go for the result and uh
resultant interpretation of the data
um
so
this is these are the two references
that have used till now this is the
paper from where this data was taken and
all the research work that they have
how they
extracted the
gene uh
that is also given here and how they
process the microarray data that is also
given here this is the data and this
paper has how
it's about
what you all need to know about dna
damage and repair regarding microarray
data
thank you from my side this is the work
that i have done
and probably i'll go for pathway
analysis in the future and
definitely share the result with you
guys again thank you